>> Tucker: THERE ARE MILLIONS
OF CENSORSHIP STORIES OUT THERE.
EVERY ONCE IN A WHILE, YOU SEE
ONE THAT'S UNBELIEVABLE.
THIS IS ONE OF THEM.
AMBER ASHLEY I WAS TALK SHOW
HOST ON A CONSERVATIVE NEWS
STATION IN WASHINGTON, WHICH IS
A GOOD STATION.
THEN SHE MADE THE MISTAKE OF
TWEETING A JOKE ABOUT THE COLOR
OF KAMALA HARRIS' PANTS SUIT
DURING THE STATE OF THE UNION.
WE'RE JUST GOING TO READ IT TO
YOU.
IT'S NOTHING TO BE EMBARRASSED
OF.
HERE'S WHAT IT SAID.
"KAMALA HARRIS LOOKS LIKE A UPS
EMPLOYEE.
WHAT CAN BROWN DO FOR YOU?
NOTHING GOOD APPARENTLY."
THAT'S A JOKE FROM THE UPS
SLOGAN.
NOT THAT FAR OUT.
A FEW DAYS LATER, LEFT WING
ACTIVIST GROUP SAID IT WAS
RACIST.
THEY CALLED ON CUMULUS WHICH
OWNS THE STATION TO FIRE HER.
SHE GOT FIRED.
SHE GOT A GREAT PIECE OF THIS ON
THE SPECTATOR TODAY.
SHE JOINS US RIGHT NOW.
THANK YOU FOR COMING ON.
IT FEELS LIKE IN THIS STORY
WE'RE MISSING PART OF IT.
THAT IS THE TWEET AND THEN YOU
GET FIRED.
ON WHAT GROUNDS?
>> IT'S A GREAT POINT, TUCKER.
I WISH THERE WAS MORE TO THE
STORY, BECAUSE THIS IS SO
INFURIATING!
BUT I HAVE A TERMINATION LETTER
THAT LAYS OUT IN VERY SPECIFIC
DETAIL IT WAS IN FACT THIS TWEET
ABOUT KAMALA HARRIS' OUTFIT.
WHAT HAPPENED HERE IS CUMULUS
THOUGHT -- AND CUMULUS IS THE
PARENT COMPANY FOR WMAL, THAT
THEY COULD JUST MAKE THIS ALL GO
AWAY AND GET THESE FEW ACTIVIST
FEMALES AND APPEASE THE MOB IF
THEY JUST FIRED ME.
THE FIRST MISTAKE IS THE WOKE
MOB IS NEVER SATISFIED.
THEY ALWAYS WANT MORE SCOUTS.
THE SECOND MISTAKE THEY MADE IS
THEY THOUGHT I WAS JUST GOING TO
ROLL OVER AND SHUT UP ABOUT
THIS.
WELL, THAT'S NOT WHO I AM.
I BELIEVE VERY DEEPLY THAT WE
ARE ALL OBLIGATED TO SPEAK OUT
WHEN INJUSTICES OCCUR IN OUR
SOCIETY AND SO I INTENDED AS
SOON AS I GOT FIRED TO VERY
LOUDY AND PROUDLY TELL EVERYBODY
ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED TO ME,
BECAUSE I THINK WE LIVE IN A
VERY PER VERSE AND SICK SOCIETY
-- PERVERSE AND SICK SOCIETY,
TUCKER, WHEN A YOUNG WOMAN WITH
A WORKING-CLASS BACKGROUND WITH
PARENTS THAT DIDN'T GO TO
COLLEGE CAN'T CRITICIZE THE
OUTFIT OF THE MOST POWERFUL
WOMAN IN THE UNITED STATES AND
WORSE THAN THAT, THE MOST
POWERFUL WOMAN IN THE UNITED
STATES IS ACTUALLY CONSIDERED
THE MARGINALIZED VICTIM IN THIS
SCENARIO.
>> Tucker: YOU BEAT ME TO IT!
I WAS GOING TO POINT THAT OUT.
THE MOST POWERFUL WOMAN IN THE
UNITED STATES IS THE
MARGINALIZED VICTIM, AND THE
BIG, SOLACE CREEPY WOKE COMPANY
TAKES HER SIDE USING I ASSUME
THE HR DEPARTMENT BECAUSE THAT'S
USUALLY THEIR NKABT.
>> I'D BE HAPPY TO SHARE THE
NAMES OF THE PEOPLE WHO FIRED
ME.
CHRISTIAN IS THE VICE PRESIDENT
OF THE HUMAN RESOURCES
DEPARTMENT FOR CUMULUS.
THEY TOLD ME STRAIGHT UP ON THIS
PHONE CALL THEY BELIEVED THAT
THE KAMALA HARRIS TWEET ABOUT
HER OUTFIT WAS IN FACT RACIST
AND VIOLATED THIS VAGUE SOCIAL
MEDIA POLICY THAT BASICALLY SAYS
YOU CAN'T DO ANYTHING THAT WOULD
BRING REPUTATIONNAL HARM UPON
THE COMPANY WHICH JUST MEANS
THEY PUT THAT IN THERE SO THEY
CAN FIRE PEOPLE FOR ANY REASON
THAT THEY WANT.
>> Tucker: I GUESS THIS IS A
RHETORICAL QUESTION BUT DID THEY
EXPLAIN HOW IT WAS RACIST?
THAT YOU WON'T IMPRESSED BY HER
OUTFIT?
DID THEY GET SPECIFIC OR JUST
CALL YOU NAMES AND FIRED YOU?
>> NO, THEY JUST CALLED ME NAMES
AND FIRED ME.
I TRIED TO DEFEND MYSELF BUT
WASN'T REALLY OFFERED THE
OPPORTUNITY.
I'M TOLD IN SUBSEQUENT MEETINGS
ABOUT THIS SITUATION THEY
ACTUALLY ADMITTED THAT THEY
DIDN'T REALLY THINK THAT THE
TWEET WAS RACIST.
WHAT REALLY MATTERED TO THEM WAS
THE PERCEPTION OF IT BEING
RACIST BY THESE REALLY BAD FACED
DISHONEST LEFT-WING ACTORS.
>> Tucker: CAN YOU REPEAT
AFTER ME BECAUSE I KNOW YOU'RE
NOW LOOKING FOR WORK.
KAMALA HARRIS LOOKS BOLD,
BEAUTIFUL AND SASSY TONIGHT.
>> KAMALA HARRIS -- I CAN'T DO
IT, TUCKER.
I CAN'T DO IT!
>> Tucker: I HOPE SOMEONE
HIRES YOU AND SOON.
I KNOW T